guys 2019 was a hell of a year 30 sports
we saw a straw 'lest take back the crown
from Team Liquid and become the first
csgo team ever to win four majors three
back-to-back in league of legends we saw
the rise of Europe before an org from
China shocked the world at worlds and in
DotA OGE became the first team ever to
win to TI's back to back no less and
don't even get me started on what
happened in the fgc
that [ __ ] was hype and while I do love a
good storyline that's not why we're here
today we're here to celebrate the very
best plays from the year these are the
plays that made us jump up and scream
these are the plays that gave us
goosebumps these are the top 10 plays
from 2019 okay guys starting off our
list of the top 10 plays of the year is
an unforgettable Rainbow six siege
clutch courtesy of young this insane one
before play happens during eg semi-final
match against BAE's clan at the pro
league season nine finals picking up
three kills oh my god after what you
might call a decisive start to the
mattress off faze clan takeout for EG
players young was left alone with the
near impossible task of closing up the
round in under 25 seconds when it comes
to young nothing is impossible just
watch but you not gonna have to abandon
ship
Astro claims to as he's getting
aggressive nvk will eventually down him
it's Yuna and MAV all alone outside but
young all alone on his roster he's gonna
end up picking up three kills oh my god
what is that God does that
what was that here's a replay for you
guys starts off with cameraman looking
the wrong way has the knit secondary
gunfight with eye on that f2 just not
winning things out then the m59 need to
clean up house Juna and math just not
coming in the clutch there at the end
and my god okay picture this
you're in a1 b3 post plant nightmare
you've got 17 health and after a couple
of whiffs time is running out
that's the situation device found
himself in in our number 9 play
taking place on the grandest stage of
them all at the starladder berlin major
this clutch practically defines back
worthy plays it was 70 HP this whole
time so many angles and look at this
lineup it is so magnificent I think
that's even his last bullet how is
device across his career continuing to
shock us all this year Tekken 7 has
brought us some of the most
heart-stopping high tension moments in
all of eSports and there's no better
embodiment of that than our number eight
play at this year's combo breaker
rickston and need duped it out in an
absolutely nail-biting around that left
Tekken fans everywhere on the edge of
their seats nearing the end of the round
with only one hit remaining for each
player rickston used his shakunetsu
hadouken in slow motion to dodge knees
overhead swing and land the final blow
leaving the audience in a state of
astonishment
[Applause]
look up in the sky it's a Farah it's a
doom fist it's sorry oh it's only a game
why do you have to be meant regardless
of how big brain you think you are an
overwatch nobody saw de France Hollywood
rooftop grab coming which is why it
takes the seventh spot on our list
what's this what are they doing right
now that is if you say that is a really
it over the roof there Oh a well-timed
alt clever use of boosting and a little
help from mosses Lucio gave us a 200 IQ
play that has cemented the Franz place
in overwatch history books to France so
watch the Lucio here as the loser is
going to use the speed to give him a
little bit of extra speed for the double
right click grenade jump coming in at
number six is a stellar equaliser goal
during Game one at the our LCS system
seven finals courtesy of vitality
[Applause]
with vitality down one and only seconds
left to go in the game
G to look poised to take an early lead
now in case you're not up on your rocket
League as soon as the clock hits zero
vitality couldn't let the ball touch the
ground leaving them no choice but to
juggle it in the air to secure a
breathtaking goal that would set them on
a course to win it all
[Applause]
[Applause]
FY crushes his way to number five on our
list with an echo slam that reminds us
why it is never a good idea to group up
against an earth shaker as well from a
Java during a mid game team fight at MDL
Disneyland Paris liquid aimed to punish
the enemy Medusa for being out of
position but they ended up getting more
than they bargained for when FY blinked
into a juicy form an echo slam that was
just too good to pass up
the team is still there down on to the
producer that this summer's world from
ER to the massive number four on our
list comes courtesy of one of go to
tools and deadliest players and yeah if
you haven't guessed it already we're
talking about our TZ and his
unbelievable 1v5 rampage from TI 9 at
least you'll be able to get one dive
back over on the Tosca oh maybe a triple
kill perrantes II
he's just turned this crap up whole
trick he'll give it the rampage to pass
[Applause]
for most dota players taking on an
entire team alone is nothing short of a
death wish
but our TZ proved to the world that that
doesn't always have to be the case after
a brutal teamfight that didn't quite go
his way
our TZ attempted to escape with a bit of
help from s4 but when VG tried to chase
him down our TZ made sure to punish the
Chinese squad we gotta get one die back
over on the Tosca
oh maybe eating a triple kill for
anything he's just heard this crap up
whole Trek he'll give it the rampage to
pass know what they say guys green isn't
always good
coming in at number three is a csgo
prodigy the savior of the french scene
and the future of counter-strike
yeah you're damn right we're talking
about xilu there's no rush this insane
one before clutch comes my way at the
ESL one cologne and is frankly a sublime
combination of raw skill big brain
tactics and a level of aggression that
would make simple blush if just one
thing goes wrong in this sequence of
events this play falls apart and team
vitality moves this map lucky for the
Frenchman design we've just doesn't do
wrong the point can only check for the
auto but not a single kill coming in all
that steps up already kills to brawl and
as I will eventually drop them on the
floor but it has to be the one before
quite strings I would
it comes in barely enough help to
survive here on parole they're both sort
of it wants to kill there's the headshot
pulled the back up and sideways got the
triple cribs is the last man standing
and there's time for the tea fuse so I
wants to smoke the ball if you're
cringing stirred and cyber wins it that
is unbelievable from the young Frenchman
a team vitality will get a sixteen
taking the runner-up spot on our list is
Breezies pistol round clutch at star
series I leaked Season eight that can
only be described as shock does breezy
actually get a plant own are the Craig's
to comment oh wait baby boy
when one thinks of hype clutches in csgo
the pistol round isn't always the thing
that comes to mind but breezy proves
that assumption wrong with these
incredible mechanics and proceeds to
absolutely dumpster renegades in this
disgusting one before for the ages
actually gonna plant own or the Krieg's
to come in there creates a comment oh
wait
[Music]
that's gonna be the best clutch at a
tournament so far that is just
remarkable witnessing a pentakill in
League of Legends is always a spectacle
to behold especially when it happens on
the game's biggest stage which is why
Vipers pentakill from Worlds takes the
number one spot on this list and is our
pick for best play of 2019 find it
either vipera stays alive that's the
full pan to kill when they need it in a
teamfight initiated by Griffin Viper
unleashes a near-perfect display of
mechanics as he pulls out everything
from his arsenal and melts Invictus
gaming with style sure it might have
only been his first world's appearance
but a play like that
is sure to be on Vipers highlight reel
for years to come what's the play for
they go they might have knocked them
down what's on the pool but they're
gonna try it on top of the tortilla two
four zero fight for another dive but one
finally comes through it's up to Jacky
love but he gets stunned clutch from
Tarzan but Morgana can't find it either
Viper stays alive that's the full Penta
kill when they needed it most
exactly what Piper has needed to do this
series
stands tall okay guys that's our list
and I gotta say it was a bang uh there
was one problem though Kyle still have
time none of my plays were in the video
I suck okay okay you know I don't have
to take this abuse in my own office
20/20 is gonna be my year if you're in
silver csgo watch out I'm coming for you
[Music]
it's my year see your if Colin okay I
got one
nice like I regretted it big time [ __ ]
[Music]